okay I went I went clear all clean every
didn't do it so I find it clear all it's
gone
I take leave everyone be cool yeah okay
so now I let a punch in this um this
next set of scores so let's do that
I mean remember you press equals to go
from one school to the next so 0 0 24 24
get out of there shift 1 to look at all
the different options and I'm going to
go for for variable I'm gonna punch
three four standard deviations okay you
still read zero maybe you haven't
actually cleaned out have you cleaned
out all of your daughter
this is
okay so this is telling me 12 okay now
what this means is think about it it's
actually very precise on average how far
away are any individuals from the mean
well in this case actually because the
mean is 12
do you notice every single one of these
people is exactly 12 away from the mean
does that make sense like this guy is
12s this is 12 this is why this is don't
want ya you with me okay all right let's
do one more for this one how to clear it
they actually shift no I will get you to
Berkley up screen and then from there
and I think you saved three
okay did you get that number yes okay
now think about this because this is a
little bit weird what's going on well
we've got a nice small set of value so
what you actually think about what's
happening here the mean is still 12
sir McCullough what's the difference
what's the distance rather from of HIV
scores from the mean well the distance
here is 12 this is you're still tall
this is still 12
how far is he from me 36 right now
what's weird about this is I said this
is the average distance from this is
like how far is everyone from the Maine
but there's actually a little bit of
fancier max that goes into you because
there's just one of him he gets waited a
little bit less so the average okay so
but you can see 20 points ma is higher
than this one and that should make sense
right you've got more people who are
further from the hand so your standard
deviation tells you these guys are your
spreader is that make sense okay now in
our sets of data so far as in many sets
of data there are repeated scores I mean
this is the worst example okay so you
can actually do something on the
calculator to help you with that watch
again closely I'll do this and then I'll
write the steps up okay if you clear
everything out I believe what you need
to do is shift setup now you've got lots
of different modes here and different
things you can muck about with can you
see up here in the top right hand corner
this is a little error right you don't
see that very often what it means is is
more options you can say if I press it
down oh okay there's a stat thing right
now if I say three for stab it says
frequency or off now at the moment it's
off so if I say 1 4 on nothing looks
like it's changed but now I have a look
at your daughter
shift one two okay so now this looks
different so this is a frequency
distribution table now rather than each
interview to score I can say the score
12 comes up four times that make sense
and I can say any number of other scores
that I want as well and how many times I
wanted to come up okay so that's the
first one I could do these other ones as
well two zeros and 224 whatever I like
okay does that make sense so the first
thing you do is make sure you're in stat
mode first that's that's the first thing
but you already know how to do that once
you've done that go I'll write this down
shift set up alright so this is for
frequency step one is shift set up do
you remember where we have to go from
this screen I have to press down like
literally I have to press the the arrow
down okay so that's the second step so
I'm just gonna put it like that mr. down
arrow here it's option 3 your staff so
press 3 cuz that says
and then once you do that it's the last
step then you want frequency on it which
is one so press 1 and frequency maternal
[Music]
yeah if you reset it I think it resets
them off which is why you need to know
how to turn one so I'm just checking